[Music]
Serena Williams says she'll be back on
the tennis court after winning a Grand
Slam title while pregnant earlier this
year the tennis star spoke with Gayle
King in Vancouver at the TED talk
conference Dana Jacobson is here with
what William shared about her love life
and pregnancy news Dana good morning
good morning Serena Williams is known
for her precision on the court but it
was actually a social media mistake
Offutt that led to her latest headlines
and while a tennis icon and
businesswoman is adding mom to her
resume as she told Gayle that will not
be slowing her down
have you thought am i coming back will I
take some time off what do you guys eat
defy the odds you know so for me
everything is really mental and I
definitely plan on coming back I'm not
done yet
even at 35 years old and with a baby on
the way
Serena Williams is confident her time on
the tennis court is far from over
but her time as a mother is about to
begin this is just a new part of my life
yeah my baby's gonna be in this dance
and hopefully cheering for me and not
crying too much Williams says she
accidentally shared the pregnancy news
on snapchat last week posting this
picture with the caption 20 weeks the
future hall-of-famer found out she was
expecting only two days before the
Australian Open in January telling Gayle
King I was nervous I wasn't sure what to
do
can i play Williams played and Williams
won beating her sister Venus while
nearly 2 months pregnant capturing a
record-setting 23rd Grand Slam title
you've had 3 life-changing things in a
six month time Williams also opened up
to Gale about her love life she's
engaged to investor and reddit founder
alexis ohanian
you saw I met a guy he's a nerdy kind of
geeky guy you won't know who he is I
said I remember talking to you about
that yeah this is a mean you said alexis
ohanian he's awesome yeah I would never
put you with the nerdy geek and you me
neither I'm gonna be honest with you I I
didn't either but it's been the best
thing for me they mean nerdy geek in a
really good way another interesting
takeaway from this interview that Gayle
did is that Williams is so competitive
she was actually angry she says when
Ohanian proposed to her because he
wanted to take her to Rome and she was
right in the middle of her training
season and she had to win the Australian
Open that it just a smidge I loved it
she also said she's number one at
winning but also number one at losing
because people say she's such a bad
loser
well she arguably the best player ever
to play women's tennis oh I think
without a doubt I don't know how you
would argue otherwise just in the era
that she's I'm up in and the way she's
helped change the game put the records
even aside she has made it a different
game for the women well winning a Grand
Slam while pregnant making the rest of
us what are you gonna do outlook